here are the two main issues that
democrats have been using for the last
let's call it i don't know two years
trump bad
and covet
and apparently now the public is done
with kovid uh where we're not done yeah
it's not like an issue anyone wants to
hear about yeah um and trump bad in my
opinion is like a much much weaker
argument so there's a fundamental
narrative that someone
uh walked me through that i tend to
agree with um this is one of the
premises of my presidential campaign
actually was that people are getting
more and more fed up and they're casting
about for some kind of answer to the
fact that stuff's not working and
government's not really delivering and
this has energy on the left and the
right and all over the place
and so you could use this as certainly
an emblem as to why bernie
was very successful and then of course
the corporate media and everyone tried
to sandbag him it's a reason why trump
was so successful that people are fed up
and then we'll
elect a person who's just like i'm just
gonna you know blow it up blow it up and
break things
this person made an argument that it was
one reason why obama was successful
against hillary um
as like a change agent um and so people
have been casting about for this
alternative and being frankly fed up and
disappointed um and he had no experience
and getting angrier and angrier all the
time because like the the
it's not delivering and there's like
this system that is built up to try and
keep anything from changing what the
people are trying to change it and
uh not being able to do so and so now
now like democracy itself is kind of
disintegrating
[Music]
all right we are back on the podcast and
we are going to be talking about
election day results we're recording
this on election day itself so some of
the results are unclear
uh but the race that everyone
is looking at is virginia's governor
race and
it's
right now too close to call i'm told
that it might actually take a minute to
count these votes because it's going to
be tight but just the fact that it's
tight actually is an enormous story in
itself because this is a state that joe
biden won by 10 points
it has gone from purple to just about
blue
and so the fact that we think there's a
good chance that virginia gets a
republican governor uh in the next
number of hours or days is a huge deal
or it's gone from blue to just about
red because it was ten points blue right
so i guess it was a blue state i don't
know this is fascinating yeah it tends a
lot so it sounds a lot but this race is
being
hailed as the future of american
politics because it's a pretty good
litmus test uh virginia
is
you could use it as a microcosm of the
country it's got some rural areas you
got some urban areas a lot of people who
are essentially commuters to dc live
there so there's like this whole wealthy
set of suburbs uh that is maybe like the
most highly contested battleground you
have a republican candidate who's i'm
going to call him this is what came to
mind for me okay i don't know who's
right i'm going to call him a mitt
romney republican because i think that's
right
the challenger here yeah he's a tall
private equity guy
uh wears fleece vests uh kind of sells
she's like a relatively normal dude
uh you know or ceo private equity guy
like mit who's a former ceo of the
carlyle group yes so he's much more mit
than trump that is for sure
and then he is squaring off against the
once governor
terry mcauliffe who's a democratic
institution
and you can see that with the panoply of
democratic
luminaries who came in campaign form
everyone came they all came obama
biden
kamala
anyone who could draw a crowd in the
democratic party over there
yeah i'm sure uh it's pretty quick
commute for them too from the white
house
yeah to get to virginia but terry
mcauliffe is a big effing deal in
democratic circles i
shared a cnn set with him multiple times
oh you know him i don't know that yeah
yeah i'm friendly with harry
and he has everyone's number in his
phone right he's like he's he's an
institution he was the governor already
now virginia has a rule where you can't
do it again until you take a break it's
kind of sort of interesting so he was
governor until 2018 and then he did
something else and now he's like and i'm
back to be governor again but the people
of virginia are not exactly
uh jumping up and down for joy
apparently that terry's back at least
you know maybe not 51 of them uh and so
there are a few things that we should
dig into here that do augur for the
future in america and number one is that
democratic enthusiasm is kind of on the
lower side
uh compared to republican enthusiasm i'm
gonna make an argument that they're not
thrilled about
terry 2.0
and you could argue like
he had a pretty seamless and well
first term let's call it if you call i
guess it's the first term right
2014-2018 he was well liked they thought
he'd be a shoe-in
in a plus 10 democratic state and that
is not the case um
so
maybe you talk more about what terry
stands for and then i could give a
rundown of what where glenn's at what
are you thinking one of the interesting
lenses that people have taken to this
virginia race
is that in part maybe because it's so
close to dc
that
democrats inability to pass the
infrastructure bill
uh really is hurting terry he's dropped
since that because what the argument is
that if democrats can demonstrate that
they deliver then that's a better case
for terry and if they can't seem to
deliver then it's a weaker case for
terry right i thought this was an
interesting argument um but there there
were a lot of people making it and
terry went on record saying please pass
something
yeah he bashed him yeah yeah he was like
hey like let's let's show the people
what we can do
that has not been delivered prior to
election day so they're saying that
could depress turn out on the other side
the republican wedge issue
that has energized their base is schools
and uh critical race theory being taught
in schools terry mcauliffe had a quote
saying that
it should be
not up to parents what's being taught in
schools it should be up to teachers and
administrators and that quote did not
fly well i actually talked to evelyn
about this um where i was like hey if a
politician were to say
that it's not up to parents what's
taught in schools it's up to
teachers and administrators like how do
you react to that and you know there is
some nuance like some things you
probably do want uh you know just for
schools to decide you know things things
that are
um
let's say fact based i mean you don't
want them teaching like different forms
of
i don't know biology
[Laughter]
or something but
um but this this certainly falls into
like a zone
where
i think parents would feel like okay
like i should have a say what's going on
in my kid's school when it's um around
something like race
uh and so this quote has really hurt
terry mcauliffe and they're saying that
if he loses this would be his like
deplorables quote
they
look i think the the rational middle
here is you want to empower great
teachers and great administrators to
create a great
positive learning environment for kids
but at the end of the day they work for
the public public school teachers work
for the public same way that
firefighters and police officers do too
um
and certainly if you're a parent you
don't want to hear that it's not up to
you yeah this is
taken out of context
yeah that's a bad quote
so
um there's a bit of a boogeyman effect
where it's like you know are you sure
that these schools are actually teaching
critical race theory and the way that
it's being described a lot of them
apparently are not right um but it's an
issue that is animating voters
and republicans are seizing on it and i
will say if glenn youngkin prevails
they're going to seize on this all over
the country because if they can make
this case successfully in virginia
they're going to try and make it
everywhere this race is fascinating
because like a microcosm for
well one it's a national race now but
it's a microcosm for the future of both
the democrats and the republicans in a
certain way because take so glenn is
running glenn yonking the republicans
running is what i call like you're
you calling mitt romney it's like you're
rich guy conservative right where it's
and he's done objectively a really good
job navigating
what's called the pro-trump side of
things and also appealing to moderate
democrats who are coming over and
independents and moderate republicans um
in this in a bunch of ways so he's
relatively moderate he says he doesn't
support abortion but
frankly he's not the type of guy to do
anything to mess with it he's against a
texas law
he's you know he's it's not a priority
for him like he navigates the social
issues social conservative side of the
republican party um he's pro guns like
pro second amendment but the nra has not
endorsed him like it's that kind of
moderate situation um
and the point is and that's what i want
to talk about is
in races like this or anyways
the why matters most in my opinion like
why are you running and he is running
his why right now is i'm a concerned
former businessman
that's concerned with how our kids are
being educated and his one of his
slogans has been parents matter um so
he's frankly navigating these culture
wars
um critical race theory which we can
dive into um
but also education our kids and that's
his why was like this is stuff that hits
parents every day and i want to be a
governor that supports parents and not
overreach of government educators and
the like and i don't know what terry's
why is on the other side like why is he
running is it
and that seems to be from listening to
biden stump
and obama's stump is that it's still
trump bad it's sell trump bad right
and that's hard so this is one of the
tough things for democrats
is that their strongest argument right
now is defeat donald trump yeah and
trump's not on the ballot uh they're
having a hard time lashing
glen yonkin to trump uh because they
seem like different humans but they keep
trying uh and so if you're making a
negative argument essentially it's like
help us defeat trump where not trump um
then people do start to ask okay like
what are you for
and democrats are having a hard time
delivering
and so that's a less compelling argument
but i i want to say that terry is in
some way is really an emblem for this
it's like terry is not generating a lot
of excitement natively and so they're
trying to bring in the star power uh and
so that this is like the new democratic
playbook it's like hey
you might not get excited about anything
i'm talking about in terms of a real
life agenda i can deliver for you might
not be that excited about the candidate
but we're going to bring in some people
that might excite you and uh you have to
help help us keep defeating donald trump
i mean that that's like really a tough
place to be there there's something
very much missing from the democratic
uh
solution set or energy or playbook um
because th this case is just getting
weaker and weaker
uh you know i said something to myself i
guess i didn't really say that much but
it's like it's like democrats had an
easier case when you can blame
everything on the crazy person it's like
hey like let's get him out and then
everything will be better but the
problem now is that he's out and people
are still sad and like and angry and
looking around being like okay you guys
are in charge what's happening they
haven't been able to deliver in any
major uh promises
you know
in terms of like some of the big ones
that they ran on and their that's one of
the dangers of this polarization is that
you end up saying look that person's bad
where you know good let's say and then
we're going to do x y z abc and then you
get in there and then you can't deliver
those things and then everyone's like
well then why did you
jin us up like this why did you get us
all motivated and be like oh but we need
you to vote again right now right now
and then people like um i'm not really
sure i'm feeling that
you know i mean there was a story that
came out about them trying to sign up
black voters in georgia and saying that
they're having a really hard time
because
uh the voters are like well you know i
did this last time or you know my
friends did this last time and what did
we get and what they were waiting for is
you know something around either voting
rights or
police reform or criminal justice they
haven't seen it and so then they get
less motivated
[Music]
[Music]
all right one thing you can do that's
going to make you feel better about
yourself is treat your body right there
are different ways to do that you could
sleep you can exercise and you can eat
better you can ingest actual nutrients
and if you are like me you want to do
the right thing but it's not always easy
to track down that kale that salad that
thing you know you should eat so you
know how you can actually solve this
problem and make yourself healthier on
the regular athletic greens you just
take one scoop you combine it with water
and it contains 75 vitamins minerals
when you drink it you know you are doing
something good for your body you know
what i mean you know when you take
something and it's like okay i just did
something really really good for myself
that is athletic greens to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com yang today again
simply visit athleticgreens.comyang
to take control of your health and give
ag-1 a try you'll be glad you did ag-1
will make you feel like you are treating
your body right and it is so easy just
take that
mix you put it in water you drink it and
you just are super charged for the day
you would say when you went to the
midwest and you talked about being a
democrat you know like the democrats can
win back mid voters in the west so they
do things that actually impact people's
lives and one of the things that's
interesting is on local races
people know what life is like like the
governor does have executive authority
to do a lot of things that touch your
daily life in a state in many states um
mayors as well these executive functions
so if the democrats are running on these
national issues like climate change and
defund the police or which is it should
be a local issue many ways but um or
medicare for all or
trump bad right um
that doesn't necessarily touch
your life specifically right as much as
like the curricula that your school
right and parents matter hits your life
right and there are
critical race theory there's a lot of
like it's a it's now a catch-all term
that means too many things different
people so people saying strong opinions
on it they probably can both be right in
many ways and how it's defined or not
defined but um
i i mean seeing
even if they're one-off small boogeyman
cases but you're seeing kids being told
that their skin color is something that
makes them evil or
less of a human or whatever it is that's
something that hits parents real hard
and the government can affect governors
very very middle of the road friends
who
are um
upset that their
white daughter came home
and essentially asked like why
uh can't i be friends with my black
classmates um
because they're being taught essentially
that uh that they are not the same that
they
uh have this
apparently like real
power differential where the
eight-year-old white girl has been made
to understand that she needs to be much
more conscious and cognizant about the
black girl situation it's made them both
self-conscious by the way she was
actually already friends with this black
girl before yeah you know some of the
these uh lessons came down the pike and
then it seems like their friendship now
is supposed to be
different or conscious of this element
so she came home and asked her parents
like why can't i be friends with my
friend anymore and her parents obviously
were horrified and angry being like of
course you can be friends right with
the
classmate you've already been friends
with and so then they went to the
administration being like what the heck
is going on in the school and they got a
response that was pretty much like no
this is the way it's going down and so
you know there there are parents that
and you know that i know that have had
this experience in real life some
version of it
so
is that happening in schools uh in
virginia uh to the extent that it would
move voters i don't know
you know some of it definitely is just
boogeyman creation where
the rest of it yeah um but i i can say
that it's happened in real life uh in
um my own network so it's not out of the
realm of possibility that something like
that's happening in households in
virginia
terry was
pressed by a um a black reporter on
local tv station to define he talked
about how critical race theory is not a
problem and the woman said well
can you define it and he refused to
define it and that's one of the biggest
challenges you have where
the actual academic of critical race
theory where it came from was an
academic term used in
postgraduate studies frankly in law
schools to basically more be more
critical about social outcomes and a
number of outcomes through the lens of
race which
i think to the average person like that
makes sense right like race is a factor
um
to be then
dumbing down versions of that for young
children um
they're more of a debate there and i
think how people define crt and carly
and i did an episode on this um
it depends where you're coming from and
how you want to find it but
are emotional about their kids right and
they see this stuff they see one they
freak out they're going to their school
board and you can this what what the
what they're talking about
in terms of teaching this is actually
transcending racial lines it is not just
the white parents getting upset about
that that may be the majority but there
are plenty of black people all right
very very
problematic
uh
yeah
one of the major issues here is that
people are defining in different ways
it's just become a political punching
bag
but i i will say this issue is a loser
for democrats yes like it's it's they
don't have the right side of this yeah
and
uh so that that is one piece of advice
i'd have is that democrats
uh you might want to try and define this
in a way that you can either
full-throatedly say hey i'm foreign and
this is what it is
um
or say look there are elements of this
that we we agree are not
something that we want to necessarily uh
you know fight for
at the the polls but right now this is
just something that that's just going to
be used by republicans um in a way that
frankly like stands up to
the point of view of more
families more parents more americans
than than the opposite
and when you get so the big thing is
that this is that and this is where i'm
curious about your thoughts on like
institutional trust and our trust in the
media like a lot of
the press on this race which is
specifically national press
is saying that young king is youngkin is
dog whistling to the right
um to the racist you know pro-trumpers
there's another one that said i'm gonna
read this headline it was in the
guardian that was uh
junkin's success is based on uh the term
was white backlash which is um
based on either crt or various
uh it's called racial
cultural lines or boogeyman whatever you
want to call it
and i don't i think some of that is is
probably true in the sense that he is
like
he means intelligently trying to not
piss off the far right of the party so
they'll turn out and vote for him
but i also think
to simplify it that way just on just
racial lines and uh this is a right well
that's one of the favorite things about
about the media is the media wants to
racialize everything
the media just wants to treat everything
in turn and also they want to take any
behaviors of a certain type and then
categorize them as capital r racist
um and that's true for certainly most
anyone with an rnx their name in the
form of a republican
um so this is just and this is one thing
that we touched on last week
it's just the media has certain
narratives they just want to beat like a
drum all the time and race is one of the
main ones because it animates reader
emotions on one side or the other it
gets you to read it um and so as long as
that's the dynamic i mean there was an
article that came out where it talked
just about things that will tap into
your emotions as being the best for
increasing digital subscribers which
makes sense for a lot of these media
organizations and race was toward the
top of the list i'm sure
to tribalism i will i mean i will say
this like there's some truth to it right
which is part like there is
like one of their last ads so one of the
hot button issues has been
the book toni morrison's beloved um in
high school i think it's high school ap
english it was unclear on what they're
actually talking about in terms of the
age but it's a book that has a lot of
graphic sexual violence and i think
bestiality it's like a very va but it's
well obviously beautifully written um
but dark um
reality of of slavery in that entire in
that era and that story um but the the
ad they run is a it's a white woman
in a like crew neck sweater with the
gold cross on talking about how she's
scared of no i don't think she even
mentions the word beloved but like the
types of material being taught in
schools and there's like panning shots
of her like all white super waspy family
over the fireplace it's like
the catering to that like that strong
demo so that was a democratic ad that
was a republican ad talking about how uh
basically there's a bill that would ban
that or require parental approval for
these types of books in or or like a
disclaimer when these types of books are
materials being taught in schools and
terry vetoed this bill i think twice
um so she's talking about this impact on
her son and it's
emotional thought it's like a little
jarring but it's also uh
i mean it's hitting a certain demo right
pretty hard um
you know there is i'm not saying you
know what's right or wrong you're you
know
it's a war if you will but it is
a tactic right i don't know your
thoughts are on that but that's a real
ad it was one of the big hot button
issues down the stretch yeah it's an
appeal to a certain type of voter um you
know i'm sure they have numbers showing
that it's effective
i i happen to think that
uh
reading those kinds of books is
generally a good thing
um
i'm trying to think about the books that
i i think it's fair to say like hey this
is like
adult stuff and you guys are the kids
are 17 and 18 and it's ap english and
letting parents know like if you have
questions about this is new things which
i don't think that's a bad thing right i
think if um
like you know i remember reading like
even like night growing up was really
you know intense right certain books i
read like uh by eli i can't remember
yeah but about the like there's stuff
you read and it's it's that sticks with
you and i think it's really important to
read when you're young and discuss um
yeah that is one of the points you know
they identify great impactful works of
literature and a lot of those things are
going to end up treading upon some tough
water yeah
um
but here's the thing i mean i think this
is the point like
talking about this is something that
impacts every parent
right in their district for good or bad
right
and talking about trump bad does not
[Music]
all right we're going to talk about
modernity
environmentalism
and tushy
oh it's true
a lot of other countries have figured
out that it's easier
on everyone if you use some water
instead of toilet paper and that's what
tushy does it's a modern bidet it just
gets affixed to your toilet i know i
know it's a little bit funny but it's
also a lot awesome it's one reason why
i'm very happy to talk tushy on the pod
tushy is practical it can reduce your
toilet paper use by 80 it saves you
money over time it's good for the planet
if this sounds good to you start washing
with tushy go to hellotushy.com yang to
get 10 off plus free shipping again
that's
hellotushi.com for 10 off and after you
buy and install it you can show it off
you can tag it on hellotushi on
instagram and then they will be very
happy with you but it's good for you
good for the planet good for everyone
yeah so here are the two main issues
that democrats have been using for the
last let's call it i don't know two
years trump bad
and covet
and apparently now the public is done
with covid uh where we're not done
yeah this is not like an issue anyone
wants to hear about yeah um and trump
bad in my opinion is like a much much
weaker argument so there's a fundamental
narrative that someone
uh walked me through that i tend to
agree with um this is one of the
premises of my presidential campaign
actually was that people are getting
more and more fed up and they're casting
about for some kind of answer to the
fact that stuff's not working and
government's not really delivering and
this has energy on the left and the
right and all over the place
and so you could use this as certainly
an emblem as to why bernie
was very successful and then of course
the corporate media and everyone tried
to sandbag him it's a reason why trump
was so successful that people are fed up
and will
elect a person who's just like i'm just
gonna you know blow it up blow it up and
break things
this person made an argument that it was
one reason why obama was successful
against hillary um
as like a change agent um and so people
have been casting about for this
alternative and being frankly fed up and
disappointed um and he had no experience
obama a lot and getting angrier and
angrier all the time because like the
the
it's not delivering and there's like
this system that is built up to try and
keep anything from changing what the
people are trying to change it and uh
not being able to do so and so now now
like democracy itself is kind of
disintegrating
um because you have these giant
entrenched institutions that will try
and keep things from changing uh they
have like a media arm that try and um
send certain messages and so this was a
case that was made to me that i
generally agree with and believe
uh it was one reason why i thought that
um
you frankly my presidential campaign
would actually get some wind beneath our
wings because it's like oh people are
fed up people are ticked off people want
something different um now i believe
that all of the things i just described
are deeply tied into the duopoly because
if you're a powerful interest you're
like okay i've got the republican party
over the democratic party i donate to
both like i can keep this thing more or
less
[Laughter]
under control
and so what we need is a multi-party
vibrant system and different points of
view by the way it would help address
some of this polarization too
and some of the
issues that you're seeing in virginia
where people are are using certain
um
cues and
being cast on different sides of these
issues in very emotional ways
um so do you have a prediction as to
what happens in virginia since we're
recording this before the results are
out so we're recording this now we may
sound like idiots if mcauliffe like runs
away with it um
but as we kind of hammer their strategy
i think
yunkan rolls i think it's a wake-up call
for the dems that's my call in my
opinion this should be a wake-up call no
matter what actually but it should
already be a dick right called really no
matter what that this stuff is not
working um
as for who pulls it out i mean i too
close to call i think we're going to be
waiting for a minute i think that
whoever loses is going to contest it and
then we'll have a little bit of a
waiting game that actually will be
interesting to see if there's if it's
close
um because one of the things young kid
has been navigating
you know the far right and that sort of
thing but
trying to navigate whether or not he
believes biden actually won the election
and um has kind of refused to answer
that question and kind of skirted and
it's it's uncomfortable for him because
he knows a lot of the bass
doesn't believe it right um but the big
mega trend that overlays all this in my
opinion is that the
uh
pessimism uh and
uh apathy are going to go up like the
the democrats ability to make their
affirmative case about hey this matters
we're going to deliver for you vote us
and vote us in is getting weaker
uh and that's you know just a sign of
where we are it's also a sign of the
polarization and the rhetoric where if
again if you get everyone super jinned
up say like hey the fate of the world is
on this election and then you win and
then you're like wait wait wait no the
fate of the world is on this other
election the fate of the world is on
this election and then that life then
was like oh
you know and uh you know like that's
just an increasingly hard case to make
you know i think
a lot of stuff comes down to it's
compelling candidates with compelling
reasons to to run i think um
and junkin has a compelling reason to
run right now he's like for the family
piece of things um it doesn't seem like
terry does i think india walton in
buffalo is a really good example people
are like how could she win she's a
socialist or xyz this is a candidate
that they're
she won the primary and now they're the
democrats are trying to
at least sometimes some of the democrats
have like written it written in right in
the encounter
she beat in the primary um but the
reality was
she was a compelling candidate with a
strong reason to run like she you know
got a whole bunch of people in the
primary to vote for her and believe in
her um appear at the end like that's
that's what happened so and there is
something very very important about this
which is that democrats sometimes don't
seem very lowercase d democratic
you know what i mean
it's like it's like hey you you lose in
the primary you're like well you know i
lost fair and square it's like no no
like this election
not
uh not right um or it's like what people
choosing bernie no no no like that
that's not right they don't know what
they're doing no they're talking about
that's the point yeah yeah there is like
a a real
anti-populist
sentiment within the democratic party
some people call it the corporate
democrats where it's like we know best
we're kind of paternalistic no no you
voted for that person that that's not
what you're supposed that's not what you
meant
yeah yeah
and and so this is something that the
republican party does seem to have over
the democratic party which the
republican party is like sorted out
what's that you elected this person that
you know is a little bit out there all
right i guess we're right we're running
with that well the people yeah whereas
the democrats are like no no no like you
know like we we can't allow that
uh and i think that's one reason why
again we need to change this dynamic
because you're going to have a
democratic party that's kind of at war
with its uh with itself
as a result because there's like this
layer of people being like this is
what's appropriate this was not
appropriate and uh and then people
getting more and more pissed off and
fervent
on one side of it and the republican
party for better for worse has
essentially gotten swallowed up by
like the
you know like the fervent opposition
um and the democratic party is trying to
present itself as like the you know the
mature adults in the room and the
professionals and the rest of it and you
can make that argument in some cases
that that is what they represent
but one of the byproducts of
that degree of
maturity or experience is also a sense
of incrementalism around the big issues
maybe in part because there are a lot of
very very big corporate interests who
already have their hooks and you are
like hey go slow go slow and you're like
yeah yeah right go slow go slow you know
um i mean the biggest thing in dc right
now that exemplifies this is the fact
they couldn't get this freaking lower
prescription drug uh
provision into the
into the mega bill
because you know the pharma lobby's
there um and so you know it's it it's
one of the causes of frustration i just
want to point out the democratic party
um it really doesn't seem to like
lowercase d democracy as much um
as you would hope uh and one
big push for us in my view is trying to
transition to a more lowercase d
democracy by having more parties because
you're in a lot of environments where
the democratic party is the only show in
town let me ask you this i saw
i just went and saw to kill mockingbird
the play so aaron sorkin wrote play and
jeff daniels in it he's atticus finch
and it's awesome if you're in new york
it was like not that expensive it was
dynamite um
one of the so i don't know if this is in
the book or not um it's been a while
since i read the book but one of my
favorite quotes from play at least and
maybe it's in the book it said uh
atticus finn says um
a person is smart
but people are dumb
um and he was talking about basically
the wisdom of the mob and that mob
mentality
and that may kind of
tie into what you're talking about
lowercase d democracy and sort of like
paternalistic aspect of our parties like
thoughts on how you navigate that
because i do think the mob can just be
completely irrational in china they're
like yeah
the crowd is dumb we're gonna have the
you know 10 of us or whatever the number
we're just going to
decide for you and how things work and
you have no say thoughts on how you
actually balance that and is it ranked
choice voting where you actually have
more options in that a little more
dynamic or what you know how does that
how do we solve for this
uh it's tough because i think people at
this point are very fed up
and some people want very very
significant changes but our institutions
aren't really designed to deliver those
changes
that's like a reasonable summary of
of where we are yeah um so in my view
the challenge is to make our
institutions capable of delivering what
people want to a much higher degree than
is currently the case that's a big big
challenge uh some people who who
looked at it being like oh you know that
that's next to impossible but i think
our two choices
are for people to essentially is just
like trash and tear down these
institutions and blow them up and blow
them up or
make them
deliver get with the program
um that that's pretty much the choice
and so you have two very difficult um
choices you know it's like neither of
them
um is easy but you know you'd rather
pursue the second
[Music]
[Music]
you know we all get down in the dump
sometime no time more so than now i mean
the honest truth is that a lot of people
are struggling right now you'd be kind
of weird if you weren't struggling but
you have to do something about it you
have to take action
and one of the absolute best ways to
take action is actually to talk to
someone
now you have friends yes you have family
members yes but they are not really cut
out to be your sounding board for a lot
of this stuff but you know who is a
licensed therapist through better help i
think of this as uber for mental health
and if you do this you're going to be so
glad because it's a professional
therapist who's on call for you whenever
you need them you can ping them day or
night you can start communicating with
someone in under 48 hours
so if this sounds like it would be good
for you and it really would be good for
just about all of us i kid you not
go to betterhelp.com as a listener to
this podcast you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang over 1 million people have taken
charge of their mental health you should
too again that's betterhelphelp.com
yang i am pumped to promote better help
because it will actually help just about
every single person
[Music]
i will say this if you're the dems and
you valued this race as a party
you gotta get some damn bills passed
before the before election day you've
had your time you know what i'm saying
like if they passed a bill i think
mcauliffe can probably
talk about it sure yeah
and so
terry is in my opinion like the emblem
of the democratic party
um he's up there you know he's like it
in many ways at least from a lot of
state level right um no no he's up there
he's a very very big deal so if he loses
it's uh
um
i don't know what to call it kind of a
it's a very very powerful
uh
like or a
reality check
for the democratic party yeah yes and
yes um and again even even if he ekes it
out i don't think democrats should take
from that like oh it's working we did it
working yeah yeah
this whole thing hang on by a thread is
not a strategy yes
hanging on by a thread is not a strategy
and again this is a state that binds one
by 10 points i mean this is not a trump
loving state what's a better strategy
hope and change or hang on by a thread
i prefer hope and change those are my
only choices
i just remember what was it is it hope
is not a strategy was that uh
i think that's a business saying hope
it's not a strategy no no that was what
the republican said to mess with obama
um i'm just remember when it was anyway
not the point moving on um
other than this and politics there's a
bunch of random things going on in the
world i think it'd be good to get your
thoughts first of all you were back in
iowa man
how was that you team iowa thank you
yang gang it was glorious man just a
trip down memory lane where i got to
uh see the sight of yangapalooza where
i rocked out with weezer and hundreds of
yang gang from around the country
i saw staffers
from the campaign who
were
you know in other parts of the midwest
who just came back for this event so it
was a bit of a reunion
uh it was wonderful it
made me really glad that i went to des
moines you know had a
great night a great event uh great
driving around campaign for a local
candidate pizza ranch pizza ranch yes
um so thank you to everyone who fueled
the campaign uh you know it was fun
being back at the site of so many of our
high water marks including the wells
fargo arena liberty just i didn't go
inside the arena but just but i
remembered walking from the ice rink to
the arena
beto dropped out like you know a couple
hundred feet away that's true and then
we
um went in and uh you know like the yang
gang was out in force in the rafters
and you know i delivered one of the
more memorable speeches of the campaign
so being back was fun and uh it made me
appreciate how much we accomplished i
have not i haven't
stomached
being able to go back uh
my worst io memory was when it was
negative 30 degrees uh
the the advice from public health
officials was don't breathe outside
don't breathe or your lungs will freeze
up and bleed yeah i was breathing
through a scarf
it was minus 30. negative 30 guys um
there's something called a bomb cyclone
i think yep it was out like there's
apparently there's an actual weather
turn
uh no thanks uh love you iowa but i
don't know if i can do it i did i i was
in iowa that day trying to campaign and
even iowans were like you know [ __ ] this
i'm not yeah well
she lives in like college town and there
were like girls going out in like
it wasn't negative 30 but let's call it
like negative five zero whatever it is
and they're wearing like little skirts
to go to the bar and she's like
no anyone no guy no bar no party is
worth what you're doing to your body
right now oh so
uh no thanks but anyway uh good to be
back uh come up other things are
interesting um and and they're all
adjacent or right on topics we've talked
about before but this one that's funny
it was a twitter
i don't wanna say spat twitter
conversation between elon musk and the
head of the one of the senior leads of
the un i think the children's fund
basically saying that um
basically there's a conversation around
taxing the billionaires to solve more
social problems elon musk gets a ton of
pressure or flack for not giving enough
charity which i don't know well there
was a cnn piece that said
uh if billionaires gave a certain amount
of money i think it's six billion
dollars it would cure world hunger six
billion would cure world hunter and elon
musk clap back elon was like hey if
someone can demonstrate to me that this
is true i will donate the six billion
dollars and sell tesla stock to do so
and then uh leader of the world food
program said look the headline is not
accurate you cannot cure world hunger
with six billion dollars but you can
feed the most food insecure 42 million
uh
yeah it would solve geopolitical
instability
in his words his name is david beasley
who is his
wfp chief which is the un world food
program
um
situation anyway that's his job and elon
suggested look if you can demonstrate to
me where all the money goes like i'll
i'll do it
um so this made some news some headlines
it didn't get i mean cnn was a piece
there was some thing but to me was um
i think was missed where there's al
there's a ton of headlines on
billionaires not giving enough
xyz but then literally one finally says
okay yeah i'll give the money if you
show me that it would work
and the answer is oh no it wouldn't work
and that's what's like you put out some
of the fire but it would just go right
back up to starting again well the the
headline was just a little bit
sensationalistic which you know it's
like care world world hunger for x
amount of money um and we all
instinctively are like can you really
cure world hunger for that much money
you might be able to feed people for a
particular period yeah i suggested that
elon give the money to
give directly and then have all the
money flow through to various people in
the developing world i thought that
would be a really nice win i think
elon's actually kind of warmed that sort
of thing because elon's not an
institution truster
and so if it was like hey look all your
money is going to go directly to a
person i think he'd prefer it
i will say having met with elon i'm
highly confident that he does not have
a giant philanthropic organization
around him the way that most
billionaires at that scale do where you
know they'd have like people and i
handle i don't think elon has that
i think i talked to a ceo when we were
on the trail i think he has a like a
donor advised fund and a couple like
infrastructure which is where you can
give like tesla stock you can give
securities um and you you get the tax
deduction the money's gone
then you just can give the charity yet
at your convenience and have it there
and it can grow tax free it's an
interesting vehicle um
but here i wanna
i have to pull this out so dave beasley
this guy's time i'm the head of the
world food program the u.n
said this this is like the the public's
bat like thousands and thousands of
people are retweeting liking this
elon with your help we can bring hope
build stability and change the future
and my skin crawled when i read that
because that is the crap that you get
from
the charity work i'm gonna call it the
charity experts if you will the
non-profit operatives who are doing
great work and they and they mean well
and they're they're nice and lovely and
they're
they're saints many times
but that's what does that mean we're
going to bring hope
build stability i guess that one is a
little more tactical and change the
future like so vague it's just tug on
your heartstrings
type operating but
in practicality the way you'd actually
fix world hunger i think you'd have to
bribe a whole bunch of people right like
you've got food
you know individuals being deprived food
in various countries that are being
controlled by people of the resources
right yeah and that is one of the
concerns is you go and you try and help
and then the
corrupt leaders end up just
stocking all the food
you know and doing things that don't
help the people now you hope the u.n has
a direct pipe to a lot of these folks
but i think we all sense that that isn't
always the case where
uh you know the
the leadership of a country can um
sometimes intercede in a way that's not
good so that there are
yeah
my hope really was that elon proceeded
and gave the money to some
good cause and one of the things that
does
really hit home for you is that at this
point he's publicly supposed to be worth
300 billion or so um for him to donate
six billion is two percent of his net
worth which is actually very doable and
you're like oh he actually could do this
right um so i hope that he ends up doing
something super positive at that scale
uh and i i wanted to recommend different
approaches if you decided that the
united nations
numbers weren't buttoned up enough or
satisfactory i mean this is the
extension challenge actually solving
some of these problems it's hard it's
complicated um
well but one of the interesting things
about this too is like a lot of people
respect elon um and admire him because
he's trying to do something
species-altering
you know and having met him he's
genuinely just wants to do something
species-altering he's like look you hit
the fast forward button long enough we
screw up this planet we got to get to
the next planet for the preservation of
the species so that's what i'm about and
i think a lot of people
love that about him and also sense that
if we left it up to
our current institutions to accomplish
the same task they'd probably be way way
way back on square one whereas elon's
already in square 18 or whatever so
so that that's in some ways the
conversation that's being had is you
have this institution uh the united
nations
uh world food program that's like look
we need money to do x y and z and then
uh someone like elon's like okay like if
we were to do it like how like how do we
do it
um
and uh someone i think in the same
article said like look you gotta you got
more than six billion dollars in the
last period and they're still world
hunger yep so that there is like this
um institutional mistrust that
built up and so elon it's like you kind
of know what you're going to get with
him and so a lot of people are like okay
like this is just a human doing human
things
uh and at this point we could use more
humanity
in a lot of areas
this is one of the big themes of the
last number of years for me it's like
humans versus institutions
and uh there are a lot of places you
know in american life where they're
trying to say no no can't trust humans
can't trust humans here's like the
institutional layer
that's going to safeguard us the org
that will help us or here's like the
pipes or like the the rest of it and
then some of us now are like subject to
these institutions being like wait a
minute i don't really love this
institution i don't think it cares about
me it doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
me and they're like no no no settle down
settle down you you you don't know
as well as we do and then more and more
of us are like
like i would really love an alternative
and then someone like elon's walking
around being like i'm like a walking
breathing alternative i'm like my own
freaking force of nature the rest of it
and some people like yay like a
beautiful person yeah and then tell
people like boo this person yeah
it just drives me nuts that
and maybe that i don't know maybe this
is like my professor
it's tough for me to boo a guy like elon
exactly you know what i'm saying where
he's like hey the world's melting so i'm
going to build a car company better than
anybody else and i'm going to leave all
the ip open for everyone um and look at
it now electric cars are a thing like
advertising for them like we don't need
gas anymore and he touches him
he's literally advanced the species um
uh already so and he's continuing to do
so so like being mad at that strikes me
as really
kind of bizarre and expecting someone to
be perfect either like also bizarre we
just it's like if you have the capacity
to advance the species
um you probably have
um some you know like uh different
uh aptitudes in other people and maybe
some gaps but like you know we should
take that as
part of the package and still be very
very glad that he's doing his thing
should be grateful
[Music]
that's the last thing i want to talk
about um
it was something we were in san
francisco
a week ago i guess this point um
so we have a lot of people probably
listen to podcasts who live in san
francisco so this is what i want to say
and i'm curious your thoughts so i've
been told like how san francisco is like
kind of it's it's the homeless problem
in san francisco is getting out of hand
it's kind of unlivable in certain parts
and you hear that you're like oh it's
overblown or they're exaggerating or
you're just like a pansy like you deal
with it like homelessness is a thing
everywhere and then we went there we
drove through downtown san francisco and
both of you and i who have been to
tough we've been all over this country
um we've seen
poverty we've seen homelessness at every
level detroit cleveland baltimore are
like all over it um
our jaws were dropped both of us it
wasn't speechless because we were like
slurring words trying to describe what
we were watching but we were in shock
how bad it was uh thoughts on
that what the hell happened san
francisco
i don't know um but just want to bring
that up now this is something i think is
very important for
uh american society generally so there
there's an attitude right now where
conservatives are just telling horror
stories around crime in their media you
can see it in fox new york approaches
being like oh um
these horrific shootings this incident
that incident by the way those things
generally true they did happen yeah and
then uh in
other left-leaning media it's like they
don't talk about
uh the crime in the same way
um there's like an omission of it in
part i think because it doesn't
run along with like particular narrative
that all failures are systemic and not
individual that um you know that that uh
and that those issues don't agree with a
particular narrative that they'd like to
present i'm going to tell a story about
my being in san francisco several weeks
ago
which is not long ago so
i i went into a walgreen
walgreens looking for some toiletries
and maybe uh and it's it ice cream
sandwiches i love those things they sell
them in walgreens so i go into the
walgreens and then um i hear and feel
like these heavy steps with someone
running towards me which you've all felt
that running out of an aisle
towards me so i just stop so i don't
collide with this person
and it's a person who's robbing the
place runs out with a bag full of goods
and there are a couple of employees
around and they just kind of look at the
person don't really do anything kind of
half-heartedly and the person just runs
out of there with a bag full of stuff
and i was like oh we just robbed this
walgreens in front of me and then
someone looked at me and literally just
said san francisco
and then i later found out that the
authorities of san francisco have said
that they will not prosecute any crime
where someone's dealing less than a
thousand dollars
and so thieves know this so they just
rob 800 and 900 worth of stuff and just
uh run right out no this happened to me
in my you know first trip into a
walgreens then the following week
walgreens announces that they're closing
that walgreens and four other walgreens
because they're just getting looted all
the time
which i'm sure the employees on one
level were
shocked by because they lost their jobs
all the people in those neighborhoods
that used to by the way rely upon those
walgreens for their
uh daily needs or whatever very very sad
uh
and i don't know if that stuff gets
reported i do know yesterday i saw a
friend from san francisco who left san
francisco and he just said look you know
it just wasn't worth it
and so that stuff i'm not sure gets
reported um but there's a real
phenomenon going on in
san francisco that anyone who spends
time there is conscious of and with a
conservative media look at it and use it
as a punching bag saying look look at
this blue city one party town they can't
control crime they have homelessness
problems
like look at the these failures
uh and then democrats look at it and say
like oh look at these you know
conservative
media outlets just with their talking
points like no empathy
what about the systematic failures that
failed the person that stole
from the
from the walgreens
down the list yeah uh or some version of
that i'm sure
um so but what's happening in real life
is people are voting with their feet you
know like my friend who left san
francisco is like and not worth it i now
depart um and so you have people who
have that mobility which is not everyone
a lot of people
can't leave
so
uh the folks with the most resources
flee
and then the people who are left behind
look around me like what the heck's
going on with this place
um and there's no real accountability
to the
public officials or authorities there
it's just their tax base flees and
they're like well you know what are you
gonna do like i mean like the harder
problem would have been i'm going to
suggest like trying to stop the robbing
of the wall greens not by the way make a
public pronouncement then you're not
going to prosecute anything less than a
thousand bucks uh you know now that
would have been harder but probably
vastly superior as an approach to the
current essentially like you know like
we're not gonna uh prosecute what they
consider minor crimes
uh
and
um that's the kind of issue that that's
happening in part because our media has
gotten so politicized that they can
argue about
the truth to that extent uh and you do
like the conservative media and you're
like ah fear mongering it's a little bit
like you know over the top um but then
you look at the democratic media and
you're like why are they not talking
about this like this is actually a thing
uh and there has to be some kind of
middle ground or reality
this this sort of thing makes me so mad
so walgreens one exam like look
walgreens has enough money they can pull
out
it sucks but it's a rounding i mean
again i feel bad for both the employees
and the residents yes i agree that but
if you're a local you have you put your
blood sweat and tears into starting a
camera business right and you sell
electronics and camera gear and someone
could walk into your store
steal a thousand bucks run right out and
the cops are gonna do nothing and no
prosecution because it was less than a
thousand dollars
that should be infuriating for everybody
i agree um
and i think
this is one of my problems as a dem as
like a i guess a former democrat if i'm
now an independent with you but uh uh
nice i don't know where i am man uh
politically homeless probably um
forward you want to continue someone
who's like
i've always struggled with the the left
on f figuring out where the line is
you know what i'm saying we're like in
terms of what's right and wrong or what
the party fundamentally stands for and
then like no no we're not going to
compromise any further than that and the
right has their line the line is nazis
right like the the nazism is like okay
that's that's bad like along the line
it's either good but it's a little more
gray but that's like they have the line
we've gone too far
on the left i don't know what the line
is
i believe the line should be robbing and
calling that okay right and looting
stores and and being okay with but um
it's it's
a little more challenging but having no
line to me is unacceptable right because
i do think that leads to
a version of communism where we're
trying to get to equal outcomes for
everyone and no one there's no incentive
to work anymore because
if you start a store people just steal
from you and i don't know like that i
don't know i don't know enough about
what the line is and that's why i kind
of like fumbled down the stretch here
but curious seven's thoughts and you're
specifically well i'm with you on and
caring deeply about small business
owners and proprietors and whatnot
because they're typically families often
immigrants themselves is trying to make
something
work uh and watching those stores
die or restaurant shutter really breaks
my heart because i just see like a
family's dream dying
uh and
nine times out of ten they put tons of
blood sweat and tears into making it
work over years um and and one of the
things that i complained about when i
was a democrat which i'm not anymore um
was that small business owners could not
stand a lot of what the democratic party
stood for because they would just think
that the democratic party is always just
bashing business of any kind and like
i'd love small businesses i think and
then some some politicians would always
be like small business is the backbone
of
you know like uh our our society or
whatnot but then when push comes to
shove then they like what did they do
for those
uh businesses
you know not not as much as uh i think
that
that should have been done so
uh
i you know
for for me obviously you know like like
putting a rubber stamp on people
stealing uh above a certain um or um or
below a certain amount is is completely
the wrong approach because it sends an
awful signal
uh and people heard that signal loud and
clear yeah
um is
the reason there's no accountability
there because it's it is a one-party
city one-party state
or the sense that
like your your leadership is just gonna
fall to the party ideology and if that
isn't
be tough on crime in the city then we're
not gonna be able to fix it well so
here's my experience talking to police
officers i've talked to a fair amount
you have yeah so police officers
will do their jobs um as they're
directed
so if a police department gets
an order saying like hey let [ __ ] go
they'll let [ __ ] go
uh and then if they get an order saying
hey
like we have to be vigilant about x y z
and now we're going to enforce that
they'll be like all right like uh you
know if you give me the resources and
backing you can do that yeah i'll do
that you know and they will sometimes
say it's like i you know
for me to be able to deliver on that i'm
going to need uh some support i'm
needing
that
you know and maybe like you know yeah
like
some kind of
confidence really some kind of provision
that like we're in it together and that
if something for example uh you know
like uh goes wrong it's not that uh
people are gonna lose their careers and
and the rest of it right um so
so in many ways it's much easier
for a leader
to adopt the let [ __ ] go tack and then
the cops would be like oh right like you
know leader wants to let [ __ ] go then
like i do yeah
what am i going to do
because the the okay let's get in the
weeds and try and solve for this stuff
ends up giving rise to like a bunch of
issues that are going to be difficult
and
fraught and interesting and maybe
politically
um you know
uh emotional uh yeah and the rest of it
um and so the path of least resistance
really leads to something like san
francisco in my opinion
that's terrifying
you know like that because i use we see
that across the country in various
cities
well most police departments would never
do what san francisco is doing yeah i i
i mean um or certainly i don't think any
mayor would come out like even if there
was like a
uh a policy they would never ever
breathe a word about it right yeah
because a lot of the deterrent is around
people just believing that stuff is
going that way you're correct right yeah
they believe in authority um and rules
and rule of law right
um
i don't know yeah i um
a lot of times we do um
when we do talk about problems on this
podcast or i talk about problems with
you we end up
coming down to a number of solutions
that would just help tremendously and
they usually include these two it's
universal basic income and
like ranked choice voting or like
breaking up the duality this camera
we're at right now um
because that probably would have for it
would offer dynamism um
well you might have some competition
solution yes you know because that's
really one of the problems you don't
have meaningful competition
things are getting a tough
you know like it's a tough run it's
going to be a tough time
uh i
you know i'm a pretty optimistic guy but
i think
even if you're optimistic you have to
see some of the things that are going on
and be like oh like this this is not
great
okay let's end on a positive note what
are you excited about between now and
next thursday it could be anything
i'm gonna have some fun um so
well a couple saturdays from now on
november 13th uh i'm doing a book talk
here in new york city that's right first
one in new york it's kind of happening
last uh we'll kick off some new dates
pretty soon i want to get back out there
as soon as i can
because it's just been such a joy
meeting people so i'm excited about that
i like that yang back on the trail
taking this show on the road yang back
on the road we will see you soon
all right that's our show we'll be a
little more positive next week love you
guys
[Music]
you